[Music] Las Vegas The Glitz and glamour capital of
the world the Los Angeles King the most exciting
and recognizable team in the National Hockey
League one in the desert the other on Frozen ice
for the first time ever the two will meet tonight
as the Kings prepare for their new season with a
historic game Outdoors at Caesar's Palace the 1991
92 Los Angeles Kings begin tonight live on Prime
[Music]
Ticket you're looking live at the world famous
Las Vegas strip in Las Vegas Nevada this gambling
and entertainment Mecca in the desert has seen
a lot of bizarre events but nothing like the one
we're going to show you tonight as the National
Hockey League goes Outdoors at Caesar's Palace
for a preseason game between the Los Angeles
Kings and the New York Rangers now my partner
again this year Jim Fox played 10 years at
right wing for the Kings he played a lot of
hockey Outdoors growing up in Ontario but I don't
think anytime did you play under conditions like
this different circumstances tonight Bob last
time I played Outdoors was about 20 years ago
it was my own backyard in Northern Ontario it was
about 10° below zero my dad just smoothed out the
snow in the backyard flooded it and we had ice
here it's different you're in the parking lot
they smooth down the sand threw down some coils
sprinkled it with water and now we have ice and
we're going to show you how they did that at the
end of the first period here tonight normally at
the start of a hockey telecast we don't have
to give you the weather conditions but we do
tonight the temperature at faceof time is really
quite comfortable it's 85° the humidity is low at
28% the wind is no Factor 7 mph the chance of
rain is 40% and the playing surface is Frozen
we hope and we hope it's going to stay that way
it looks pretty good right now you know in the
excitement of playing here in the desert Outdoors
at Caesar's Palace we also have the excitement
of seeing one of the great combinations ever in
the history of the National Hockey League Wayne
Gretzky and Yari Curry playing for the first
time together in a Los Angeles King uniform and
I'm really looking forward to that if you can
believe this Yari Curley will will make Wayne
Gretzky a better player he knows Gretzky better
than any other player they had many great years
in Edmonton Gretzky's on attack Curry knows where
to go if he senses trouble from Wayne grety Yari
Curry knows to hang hang back playing for the New
York Rangers tonight will be an old friend of the
Los Angeles Kings Bernie Nicholls and Bernie is
having one of the best training camps he's ever
had he'll be counted on again once again this
season Bernie comes into training camp this
year in the best shape of his life another old
friend Mark Hardy took Bernie under his wing
this summer and made Bernie work out for the
first time probably in his career he really
concentrated on his physical fitness and that's
going to help Bernie Nichols he's coming around
the 30y old Mark and it's he needs to get in
shape to keep up in the NHL we're going to
have a crowd of about 13,000 and more more here
at Caesar's Palace we're out on the parking lot
just behind the the hotel there's Yari Curry
coming on to the ice being introduced but the
players feel the ice is safe to go at it and the
coaches very secure that there will be no injuries
tonight obviously injuries to Wayne Gretzky in the
Canada the cup a big concern of Tom Webster but
the ice is ready and so are the Kings and the
Rangers and the golender for tonight John Van
bees Brook for the New York rang ERS winner
of 15 games last season goals against 3.35
and Kelly Rudy for the Kings he won 26 games
last year and had a goals against average of
2.90 the referee in the game tonight will be
Rob schik and the linesmen will be Mike Civic
and Shane higher Rob schik talking with rain
Gretzky right now they seem to be concerned
Jim about the blue line right there you were out
on the ice and that blue line seems to be coming
loose a little bit apparently it's not that
far under the ice different than normal the
lines tonight are a fabric that is underneath the
frozen water usually you have painted lines and
that's what they're doing right now they're
putting some snow on top of that trying to
freeze it down because unlike paint it is a
fabric and once you hit that with your skate
you're going to stop immediately the Kings had
several members of the team in the Canada Cup
Wayne Gretzky and Luke robai for Canada you
can see Gretzky had 12 points Tony ronado
for the United States Thomas sandstrom played
for Sweden and Yari Curry for [Music] Finland
tonight's opening Face Off is brought to you
by AIS for lowcost auto insurance call the
Auto Insurance Specialist and we're underway
with hockey in the desert at Caesar's Palace
as the Kings Drive it into the ranger Zone
Kings for the Rangers drive it back behind
the kingn net and Rudy puts it into the corner
there's Louie de Brusque a big tough guy and his
pass knocked down and now taken by Tim waters for
the Kings Rangers intercept there's Amonte with a
shot and a save by Kelly Rudy Rod Buscus with
it Rangers have it again shot by Amante and he
scores Tony
Amante 21-year-old rookie out of Boston University
puts the New York Rangers ahead one to nothing
Bernie Nicholls the former King setting up
behind the net much like wings Gretzky does
he gets the puck coming around the boards and
Amonte moves to the opening a soft pass from
Nichols Amonte able to shoot on the Fly Kelly
Rudy with no chance a point blank shot right
a rookie sends it into the king Zone and he gets
it back again and tried to center it in front and
a saved by Rudy rebound score as Doug Wright
got the rebound and the Rangers lead two to
nothing the kings were sloppy in trying to clear
the puck they hand possession but gave it right
back to Doug Wright on the right side and then
he got a rebound right in front of the net the
first shot was by Ty doy and the rebound came
over to Doug Wright number 39 and he put it in
once again the Kings having trouble behind their
own goal line the puck comes out in front of the
net Rudy will make the first stop but there's the
rebound right wide open net Kelly Rudy following
the puck once again but the puck moves faster than
he can he makes the first stop the Kings have to
clear there's a wide open stick in the Rangers
lead two to nothing pass head to Nicholls with
room left side Amonte with him but a stroken up on
his shot by De bras is knocked away rebound save
on the shot as Kelly Rudy Dives to make the save
on Tony Amonte a goal tenders view Bernie Nichols
on the right side Rudy following the puck Tonio
Monte comes in Kelly Rudy very sharp early here
for the Kings the new Rangers buzzing all around
the king's end there's another backhand shot and
Rudy following the puck all the way top of the
slot knocked down kicked ahead by Jim Thompson
Thompson up on the right side with a Roba tie but
his pass out of his reach here's kadelski left
side he gets checked hard but he knocked down the
Ranger and the puckle on the board's left side now
taken in front by roai save rebound steered Away
by Van Baybrook I actually I played now to left
here in ity you know we played in CA was outdoor
and U first game there were cancel because was
snowing and second game was - 15 cels so I had a
good experience but playing in vas is something I
hard to play happen but it going to be funny David
Shaw with it for the Rangers but it's taken away
by Waters he gives it to Gretzky Gretzky's blind
pass off the right side curry with a shot and
a pad save by John Van bebook still two nothing
Rangers kety behind the net ketky Rangers Z kety
tried to go it through the slot to curry curry
plays it off the board here's jry curry with it
his pass he tried to beat it through to Gretzky
deflected now Sans grety shoots and a save by
Van bebook Gretzky again behind the net ketky to
sandstrom up in the air and he couldn't get it on
his stick and at the end of one it's the Rangers
two and the Los Angeles Kings [Music] nothing Las
Vegas a glittering Oasis in the middle of a desert
Las Vegas has always been known for its sense of
Glamour and adventure but tonight there's a new
kind of excitement as Nevada enters the Ice Age
last week while sunbathers were enjoying the heat
just around the corner from them construction
workers were starting a project that actually
began several years ago and like everything else
in Las Vegas this one was also quite a gamble
it uh been about 3 years in the making we came
up with it just by that that idea of what can
you do that no one else has done what can you
do that's different and this outdoor Arena has
has been here it's uh hosted many of the great
world championship fights and we thought what can
we do that that's different that that people will
come and see and the thought was what about ice
hockey and when everybody got over the initial
shock of are you serious uh they said let's go
find out if we can do it and 3 years later here
it is this is probably the biggest challenge in
my my life to make ice in the desert at 98° but
we spent a lot of time perfecting it and uh a
lot of time engineering it before we attempt
to even tell seasar we' even try it we arrived
here on a week ago Monday it was the 16th of uh
September we put it all together last week and
we started the refrigeration equipment Sunday
morning at 10:00 at that time the sand was 120°
in temperature the temperature outside was 92
we turned the Machinery on and pulled the floor
from uh 88° circulated liquids down to 16 deges
in 2 and 1/2 hours the organizers at Caesar's
Palace hope tonight is the beginning of a new
era in hockey took a little while to resurface the
ice here between periods as Kelly Rudy gets set
again the plan as far as I know tonight is for
Kelly to go all the way in goal and now you're
looking at the view that Kelly Rudy gets from what
we call the Rudy cam the camera mounted on top of
Kelly Rudy's helmet you see a whack on the head
from Wayne Gretzky who does Wayne Gretzky share
the record with for most 50 goal seasons and our
hint is he is a recent NHL Hall of Fame inductee
they had that ceremony in Ottawa just last week
here's Cory Millan for the Rangers his pass off
on the right side James Patrick in deep wrap
around pass in front and it's knocked down by
Rudy and a penalty coming up holding is the call
as Cory Millan came in for the Rangers and tried
to just redirect it behind Kelly Rudy again at
the beginning of the second period the Rangers off
quick with an attack James Patrick behind the net
throws it in front but Kelly Rudy never out of the
play Kelly Rudy never losing sight of the puck
keeping his eye on it Graves fires it down in
deep and Larry Robinson moves it up the middle
here's newcomer Randy Gillan to the Kings Gill
to the Blue Line gillan's pass left side and
a shot from there is knocked down donaly got
the shot from the net is disl Bernie Nichols is
going to get a penalty here for the Rangers for
delay of the game two minutes to Bernie Nichols
for delay of the game Nicholls was back checking
on the play coming right down the slot and
he did not stop he just went right through
the net that caused the stoppage in play now
we're ready to go again and Bob kadelski on
the face off of the Rangers Zone with 1105
left to go in the second period Rangers up
two to nothing now down in deep the king Z
a check thrown by Jody Hull on Benning but
the kings are going to move it up toward
the center ice area where it's taken by
Shaw and HUD he ran into him pass on the
right side to Granado Granado shoots he
scores Tony Granado with the first official
goal ever scored by a king in a parking lot
as he drives it from the right side an assist to
Charlie huy and the kings are down by one at two
to one power play goal by Tony Granado the play
starts early and Charlie hutti with a collision
here against the Rangers and the loose Puck is
taken by kadelski he feeds Granado he had Roba a
two on one then beastbrook up to the top of his
crease but did not cut down the angle Granado
fires it by John vanbrook the Kings getting back
into this game they've opened it up a little bit
in the second period last time I was outdoors
I was skting on pond back home and out in the
middle of our pasture field and uh for sure
a little bit colder than it is at least down
here in Las Vegas but because we had no trees
to block the wind or anything but uh it's a
lot of fun you always have fun playing outside
so this is going pretty good John McIntyre with
his experiences Outdoors Rob shik the referee
tonight said the last time he skated Outdoors
he fell through the ice I think you'll hear from
some of those players uh in a king uniform uh in
their careers because as you mentioned some of
them have some outstanding skills there's a shot
by Cory Millan from the left side knocked down
well that vukonich comes out of Harvard and I'll
tell you he whistled a couple of good shots
there s moving in over to Curry to Benning he
scores Benning got the puck from Yari Curry and
Benning ties the game at two to2 it's got to be
a goenda sandrom and Yari Curry are rushing in
on you they both have outstanding shots this
time they show how unselfish they are sandrom
coming with speed from behind the play he puts
it over to curry curry really not in a shooting
position Taps it to Brian Benning Benning winds
up and ties it up for the Kings there's it out
to Center Rangers take over Joe Cella cella's
pass stolen nicely by Buscus he's got cier with
him left side he shoots it's deflected up and
out of play by the Rangers Peter fiorentino
and the shirt sleeve crowd enjoying the game
and the souvenirs here at Caesar's Palace Doug
waight for the Rangers and the Kings win the
draw with a minute 38 left to go in the second
period we are Outdoors at Caesar's Palace the
last outdoor game of the NHL 1925 in December
the Montreal Maroons play tonight here's Taylor
driving down the right side and it comes over
wide over to Doug weight but Taylor over to
take it away here's Taylor he's got McIntyre
up the middle buus shoots save rebound score
cier
with their third goal of the second period the
Kings have t taken the lead at 3 to2 silvane
couturier who had 50 goals at Phoenix last year
the Kings got a lucky break the puck going along
the boards here I believe it's Doug Wade his
stick gets caught in the boards then McIntyre
going to the net strong opens it up for Buscus
van bees Brook with the first stop but coutou
he's a big guy 6 for3 hanging around the creas
he bangs in the backhander McIntyre wide open
there also the Rangers have to do a better job
clearing the front of the net Gretzky with it
ahead to curry curry behind the ranger net
Curry to Buscus Buscus Drive is wide rebound
bretzky can't get to it Puck comes to Center
Cory Millan chasing it down right wing Millan
King Z goes behind the net and got tripped up
and into the boards I didn't see a signal for
any penalty time has run out and a good period for
the Los Angeles Kings goals by Tony Granado Brian
Benning and syane Couer have given the Kings
a 3-2 lead over the Rangers in this preseason
game Kings at the end of two periods all the
king goals came in the second period time to
show you the Jack in the Box highlights and Tony
Granado got it started nothing fancy here from
Granado he winds up with a slap shot Ben Beck
way in front of his crease but he did not cut
down the angle and the Kings getting back into
the game at that point the Rangers LED two to
one huy and kadelski with the assist and Brian
Benning tied it up Brian Benning reads the rush
as well as any King's defenseman he reads Wayne
Gretzky well this time though it's sandstrom with
a backhand pass to Yari curry curry just stops
the puck doesn't really pass it and benning's
there winding up for The Slap Shot the Kings
tie it up two to2 Benning with his first of
the preseason from Curry and sandstrom at 11:23
and then the Kings took the lead on the goal by
sane coutur John McIntyre drives to the net
and opens up the slot for Buscus he gets the
shot on goal there's two kings waiting for the
rebound and it's Couer putting the Kings up on
the Toyota statue to the end of two periods it's
3-2 in favor of the kings in this preseason game
each team at 13 shots in the second period Rangers
25 Kings 22 each team has had 10 scoring chances
and on the specialty teams Rangers 0 for five
Kings one for four on the power play I don't
think you'll see a driver dressed like that at
the Great Western Forum or any other building
in the NHL this year here are the odds on the
Stanley Cup this year published today at Caesar
Sportsbook and look at the odds on the Kings to
win the Stanley Cup gy the Edmonton Oilers there
10 to1 yeah there's some te9 as you go on down
if you'd like to uh risk your money a little bit
more you can bet on Toronto at 75 to1 and if you
really want to risk your money pick the San Jose
Sharks to win the Stanley Cup in their first year
200 to1 Wayne Gretzky out at Center ice for the
third period Faceoff which is brought to by AIS
the Auto Insurance Specialists play underway in
the third period long pass on the right wing to
Yari Curry is out of his reach Rangers Chase it
in and they will move it up on the right side
now to the blue line to Tai DOI he got it from
Pair juice but Curry took it away here's Thomas
sandr play it off the boards to Curry and the
Rangers are going to take it away that was a nice
move if it had worked but it didn't the Rangers
broke it up from tyomi chasing it down into the
kick Zone Charlie huy with it comes off the glass
here's Wayne Gretzky Gretzky not on the scoreboard
yet tonight in the slot right side shot by Curry
scores we'll see that a lot this year Wayne grety
giving it to yui Curry who scores for the first
time in a uniform and the Kings lead 4 to2 it's
been a while since Yari Curry has played with
Wayne grety but they have not forgot a thing two
or three passes back and forth and finally Curry
he doesn't even look up he's so aware out there
he buries the puck the king's now up by two goals
Gretzky's pass right on the stick between the
Rangers defenseman feet and stick and Yari curri
with with his first goal here in Las Vegas the
Kings now with a two-goal lead I remember when I
was still with the Canadians we went to to Lake
Tahoe and I remember going out uh extra early
because um we stayed in squa Valley and the whole
one side of the rink was wide open and it it was
you know like being outdoors and kind of brings
back the old days and the fun fresh air and U not
having to breathe all the smug last year's scoring
leaders there you see Wayne Gretzky Gretzky with
163 points as he led the league in scoring for the
ninth time Rangers set it up on the power plate
PIR juice at the Blue Line still with it his pass
deflected by the Kings a pass ahead here as guty
on a breakaway all alone in front he shoots saved
by van beastbrook on the short-handed attempt by
Gretzky who continues to have trouble with that
Breakaway across the line here's jari Curry but
his pass knocked down britzky almost stole it
held in shot by ju in a save rebound saved by
Rudy Louie de brusa on the rebound can't get
a shot two seconds to go in the power play and
Curry moves it ahead toward Gretzky kings are
back at full strength oneon-one Wayne Gretzky
against John Van beastbrook Gretzky slowing down
who makes the first move it's Gretzky going to his
backand and Van bees Brook picked up by robotti
ahead the center broken up he tried to get it to
Gretzky and joose Cella stepped in front to take
it away now Nicholls had it for a moment taken
away by sandram ahead to Gretzky at Center grety
had to turn around and knock it down he got it to
robotti here's robito over to Tony gonado looking
for his second of the night stops he gets knocked
down he shoots and a save and a penalty coming
up against the Rangers but Tony did a great job
to get a shot off after he got knocked down Joe
sella of the Rangers off for tripping at 1201 Tony
Granado great speed he darts in and out this time
outside in for Granado and there he gets tripped
intensity he keeps his eye on the puck gets a shot
on goal Cony Granado gives all of the defenseman
in the NHL trouble he's just so quick it's hard to
keep up with him and Cella goes off for tripping
time to give you the answer to our trivia question
who does Wayne Gretzky share the record with for
the most 50 goal Seasons we mentioned he was just
inducted into the NHL Hall of Fame the great Mike
bossing 50 or more goals 1977-78 to 1985 86 and
a real shame that a back injury cut short his
career here is Paul Bron for the Rangers sends
it in wide of the net Lou de brusa goes for it
he's checked by Waters as the puck comes loose
along the boards and the Rangers will hold it in
but it's taken away now here Jerry curry curry
to Gretzky tried to give it a head now towards
sander McCurry but it's brok up Gretzky gets
it back grety Rangers own right side shoots he
scores the fifth unanswered goal for the Kings
and they laid the Rangers five to2 when you shoot
as accurately as Wayne Gretzky does you don't
have to get a lot on that shot a turnover at
the Rangers blue line grety waiting around and
he picks it off he pickpockets the Rangers goes
in on goal doesn't get a hard shot off once
again vanbrook beaten on a bad angle shot and
when Wayne Gretzky takes a shot you give him
credit here's James Patrick at the right Point
his pass is held in on the right side by Louie
de brus for the Rangers I think de brus got a
punch from Benning look out for him shot from the
Blue Line deflected up over Rudy debrus a tough
customer and it looked like Benning took a whack
at him but play continued so debrus continues in
the play I think the Kelly or the Rudy cam was
a real success too tonight Jim we got some nice
views from the top of Kelly Rudy's helmet here's
one of them she has to follow the puck and you can
see makes the kick save once again there it'll be
fun for the fans this year if we can continue with
the Rudy cam but there is a tough connection it
has to be taped to his helmet a lot of wires it
can be bulky inside the pants of Kelly Rudy there
but if it works out I'm sure the fans will enjoy
seeing the puck coming at a go tender over 100
milph you know how superstitious players are he
wins tonight he may wear that thing the rest of
the year game is going to end here as the king's
clearing to Center Ice 1 second to go and it's
all [Applause] over outdoor hockey in the desert
for the first time ever in NHL history and this
their 75th Anniversary Year and a happy bunch
of Kings come up to congratulate Kelly Rudy and
even got a good look at the congratulations on
the Rudy C all right thanks very much Bob another
solid night in the nets for Kelly Rudy 30 saves
you came in with a big smile on your on your
face you said you really enjoyed playing before
this crowd I really did this is uh this is quite
different than anything else we've ever done in
the past before and uh I've never been to Vegas
myself so it's kind of exciting that way we came
in yesterday there's three of us that came in
yesterday for a little bit of a a media event
and it was kind of fun I mean I haven't played
outdoors in years and years since I was a kid
and uh it the ice was great the ice was better as
I was saying than some of the places we played in
the past in preseason and and uh the only thing
there's grasshoppers on the ice I've never seen
that before I don't think anybody has either and
people at 5:00 this afternoon very nervous about
the ice conditions but they turned out to be very
very good all right Paul thank you very much nice
to have you with us this year and congratulations
to Kelly Rudy the Evan player of the game he had
30 saves tonight allowed two goals as the Kings
beat the New York Rangers in this preseason game
[Applause]
5-2